unter den schwerverletzten ist auch ein
polizist und ein ersthelfer hat dem
polizist geholfen
wir waren wir wollten eigentlich
gesunden letzten kaffee von lok dann
trinken ja dabei ist es natürlich nicht
einmal gekommen
auf einmal sind sind die ersten schüsse
gefallen und wir waren mitten im gefecht
drinnen werden wo wart ihr da am
schwedenplatz lange das tor
wir waren graz wir waren beim aussteigen
wir waren gerade der mischung aus not
aber dann sind die schüsse gefallen mir
mein freund mein freund rechtzeitig hat
hat eine dame am boden liegen sie die
war verletzt die war jetzt auf mehr
er hat die dame aufgehoben zum nächsten
bar casablanca hinein gebracht und dann
ist er wieder schnell schnell zum auto
eingestiegen
wir sind einfach zur nächsten
polizeistation durch durchgehend durch
gesichter das heißt du warst im auto als
ich ich war im auto muss ja ich wollte
eigentlich aber dazu ist es nicht
gekommen
dann sind wir auf den auf jeden fall
zunächst die polizeistation er die
polizeibeamten die waren schon bei der
vorbereitung in schutzwesten an zu
ziehen wir haben ihnen die sache
geschildert wie das wie das alles
geschehen ist ja mein freund hat erklärt
was für ein was für einer waffe der
terrorist in seiner hand gehabt in
diesem jahr er hat den er den er den
werten aus 5 5 bis 6 meter abstand meyer
hat er den ein gesicht gesehen hat er
auch auf ihn gezielt auf die auf hin
wurde natürlich gezielt deswegen hat er
auch eine bekommen
wir wollten eigentlich dann nach der
produktion wollte eigentlich komplett
weg fahrer war ja meine alte wir haben
eine alte dame gesehen
die war wahrscheinlich mit 80 ja- und
dies dies richtung richtung des
geschehens einfach einfach
einfach rein gelaufen und hatte
überhaupt keine ahnung vielleicht hat
sie auch schwer gehört kanal
was machen wir wie stein raus und helfen
der dame weil wir es müssen wir haben
sie werden die dame zu sicherheit
gebracht ja und dann sind die nächsten
schüsse gefallen und dann laut video
sehen sie wie wir die wir uns verstecken
wetter vor bewegen und das zweite
schüsse waren dann auch euro
unmittelbaren die geologen so 20 meter
dann haben wir natürlich den verletzten
verwundeten polizei am boden gesehen da
waren noch 2 bgb also von der spitze
neben mir aber die rettungskräfte mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren